[Musique]
couvrez ce sein que je ne saurais voir
télé lui dit-on d'instagram si l'on en
croit les conditions générales de
facebook instagram et compagnie qui
interdisent toute apparition de téton
féminin sur leurs plateformes et madonna
en a fait les frais ce week-end après
avoir posté une série photo la
plateforme à censurer son poste estimant
que son état était partiellement visible
une décision qui a rendu furieux de la
star de la pop qui a dénoncé
l'hypocrisie des réseaux sociaux c'est
toujours étonnant pour moi que nous
vivions dans une culture qui permet de
montrer chaque centimètre du corps d'une
femme à l'exception d'un téton comme si
c'était la seule partie de l'anatomie
d'une femme qui pouvaient être sexualisé
pas de là donc décidé de reporter les
poteaux avec un petit emoji coeur venant
couvrir son sein cette fois ci alors
censuré pour un téton soutenez-vous
madonna après son coup de gueule
[Applaudissements]
non non non alors oui benhaim tu la
fille elle a raison sur l'hypocrisie on
n'arrête pas de faire de la de corps de
la femme un objet ou de l' hyper
sexualisée et on n'est pas obligés de
montrer un téton pour hypersexualisée le
corps de la femme et on est en revanche
on peut très bien montré on l'a vu des
tableaux le tableau de courbet la ville
et l'autre à l'origine du monde sans
aucun doute par exemple et qu'on censure
donc vraiment c'est évidemment un
algorithme qui travaillent qui font ce
genre de choses mais il ya une
hypocrisie totale des plateformes même
quand je vois ces tableaux magnifiques
de foot bergues l'oiseau est le fruit
d'un câble en france bergues
jonas folger il a explosé ou pas
du tout d'accord avec valérie ras-le-bol
de madonna
tu apprends la plante a touché c'était
pour moi une icône absolue et
aujourd'hui elle n'est plus rien le fait
de la promo
derrière tous les 1000 guinées s'agit
uniquement pour faire parler d'elle pour
épurer alors
sachez cependant que ça c'est exactement
ça pour hier mais grave en isabelle
bravo les discours sur le même match
avec madonna oui le discount et ont il
est vrai les américains une espèce de
phobie de tout ce qui est poitrine alors
qu'ils permettent tous dressent en
revanche pardon mais elle est une
caricature de berne elle fait sens
unique c'est recommencer parce que parce
que nous séparent de kanaky arts et
culture de vous-même l'a jamais nous
amène hp à votre question je l'aurais
mur à vérifier mais bon sans contrainte
et on tue c'est ce qui est fou que
l'appareil j'en ai d'abord
vous êtes magnifique si on tombe dedans
peut-être qu'on y arrivera les points
l'instant
est ce que je peux dire un mot sur
l'hypocrisie et l'annoncé a fait passer
une soirée avec magali bernard
[Rires]
comment faire de la tête de redescendre
à fond non mais sans déconner berda
bernal d'aller la voir inquiétez pas la
dll et les prix a surtout là elle a tout
fait refaire pour un mois au 50 m ah oui
elle est repartie comme neuf là j'ai vu
rouler en à la fois
magnifique magalie vaé vous vous n'avez
rien à faire vous êtes magnifiques comme
ça
c'est une femme est magnifique je me le
dire voilà oui madame
des mois c'est aberrant c'est que même
votre on a posé pas passer d'autres
photos parce que les photos elle il faut
couvrir un téton mais des photos elle a
les fesses à l'air avec comme ça sur
après sa pause aucun revenu à l'excuser
alliés mais l'épaisse comme meehan a
aucun problème ni robben photo comment
sur l'instant d'où les mêmes intrigues
la pause il est passé franchement elle
est pas mal à les servir et les pires
que l'équipe à paris les passagers par
mois
attention la loi
on est non pas monde aux urnes
vous dis
pas qu'on ne regarde comme ça non plus
quoi faire je pâques comme l'accueil
virgin à
[Applaudissements]
merci
à mon psy bien entendu c'est pas ton
délire je vais vous donner à paroles
mais pas sur ce sujet pourquoi je ne
vous sent pas la pertinence ne le sont
pas mais de même agi d'accord avec
valérie avec mathieu effectivement c'est
hypocrite c'est ridicule et il ya une
sorte de je sais pas de de snobisme des
chenaux bl oui parce qu'en fait non au
monde écrou on monte des faits sans nom
des raids eu voilà et là forcément il ya
des trous alors ça m'a gêné tout le
monde alors qu'une récente on
aujourd'hui du plan dans thalassa
vitalisme absolument obscènes et
dégueulasse et moi je trouve que c'est
ridicule et en plus par do is a mais on
s'en faut qu'elle ait des saints comme
ça qu'elles soient refaites qu'elle est
du moteur calé des faussaires enfin je
veux dire pourquoi tu vas la juger par
rapport à ça j'ai juste pas choqués sont
aussi extrêmement vulgaire mais les
génies je trouve yoplait il ya delphine
qui voudraient parler
je suis là étaient rares au gîte en
train de conduire de
brittany snow stop mais c'est pas ça m'a
donné a dit que cette décision elle est
injuste parce qu on sous-entend qu'un
tétons d'homme c'est aussi sexualisé qu
un téton de femmes maintenant désolé
c'est pas vrai à la plate forme les
hommes ils sont torse nu les fameuses
armes et demain matin le père et les
cinq branches à manger non mais
dans les pubs pour des sous-vêtements
les hommes c'est qu'ils ont vu les siens
sain nourricier c'est pas pour turin
d'accord mais une femme je montre ses
seins sont donc ces saints désolé c'est
une connotation aujourd'hui sauf dans
les ans que tu viens de citer c'est une
connotation sexuelle et à force de
vouloir chanter avec un saint il peut
nourrir une planète entière mais voilà à
force de dire qu'on est tous égaux est
tous pareil on dit n'importe quoi et
vraiment que dfs aucune règle quand elle
montré le fait c'est une ré c'est pas
moi qui le dit mais c'est ce qu'on dit
et ont esquinté pas l'âme c'est
sexualise aujourd'hui
zaoui une ré s'est sectionné bah oui
dresser solis et non ah oui bah quand
même ça dépend quel horaire sinon la
cacherai pas cantonné sens qu'à
l'antenne ah oui paris de samba ont fait
beaucoup de we fall à
l'arrêt a l'air alors vous avez les
autres en cadets 1 bah oui bonsoir
bonsoir qui arrivait de villiers
l'appareil ça les a pas de doute mais
j'appelle des matches et elle a laissé
pas là non moi ce que je voulais dire
c'est que je trouve que e.on pourrait y
voit un côté positif soyons un petit peu
positif en moulin avec les autres et je
trouve qu'ils aient nouvelles règles sur
instagram qui est cette règle
d'algorithmes de cacher les tétons je
trouve que c'est quand même une belle
avancée sur les réseaux sociaux et que
on peut se dire que maintenant ça va les
encourager à cacher d'autres choses du
corps de la femme parce qu'on voit trop
de gens à poil sur instagram et pourquoi
pas commencer par les tétons et en films
à faire les ré tout ce qu'il faut mais
je pense que c'est une belle avancée je
vais avoir fait
c'est bon - photo par contre mettais ma
pochette là ça y est